The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Okay.
Great.
Let me just pick up where we
left off on Friday.
And that is we were talking
about some of the physical and
chemical properties of the
elements as we go across or down
the Periodic Table.
And one of those properties
that we were talking about was
the electron affinity,
which I defined for shorthand
just as EA.
And we saw that,
for example,
if we add an electron to
chlorine to make the anion,
chlorine minus,
that there is an energy change
associated with that reaction.
And that energy change was
minus 349 kilojoules.
And what we saw is that the
electron affinity is defined as
the negative of this energy.
So the electron affinity,
here, is minus this delta E.
So if you have a reaction that
you write with something plus an
electron to give the anion here,
the change in that energy is
this, in the case of chlorine,
but the electron affinity is
defined as minus that.
All right.
So chlorine we say has an
electron affinity of 349
kilojoules per mole.
And it is positive.
Now, unlike the ionization
energy, the electron affinity
can be negative.
For example,
if you take nitrogen and you
try to stick an electron on it
to make N minus,
delta E for this reaction is
positive.
When delta E is positive it
means, of course,
that the anion,
the product here,
is less stable than the
reactant or the neutral atom.
You cannot put an electron onto
nitrogen.
It won't stay there.
It will fall apart.
It is not bound.
And, therefore,
nitrogen here,
the electron affinity of a
nitrogen atom is minus 7
kilojoules per mole.
So you can have a negative
electron affinity.
So nitrogen has a negative
And you can understand it in
terms of the electronic
structure of nitrogen.
If you draw the states of
nitrogen and put the electrons
in the states here,
here is the electronic
structure of nitrogen,
just nitrogen neutral.
But now if you go and you try
to add another electron to the
nitrogen, it's going to have to
go into one of these filled
states.
There is a repulsion between
these two electrons.
That repulsive interaction is
large enough so that the
attractive interaction between
the electrons and the nucleus is
not great enough to overcome
that negative interaction,
that repulsive interaction.
And, therefore,
the electron affinity here is
negative or, in other words,
this delta E here is positive.
So you can understand that in
terms of the electronic
structure.
The other atoms that have
negative electron affinities are
the inner gases.
Here is a plot of the electron
affinities.
Here are all the inner gases.
They all have negative electron
affinities, because you're
trying to put an electron in the
next shell.
That's a higher energy state.
The charge on the nucleus is
not large enough to compensate
for that extra energy to promote
that electron,
to put that electron in that
higher energy state.
All right.
So let's look at what happens
here as we go across the
Periodic Table to the electron
affinities.
As you go across the Periodic
Table, the bottom line is,
in general, that the electron
affinities increase.
They get larger as you go
across the Periodic Table.
They get larger because the Z
on the nucleus is getting
larger.
The charge on the nucleus is
getting larger.
When that charge gets larger,
the Coulombic interaction
between the nucleus and the
electrons is greater.
And if that's greater,
well, then the electron
affinity here is going to go up.
And it's greater because
remember, that potential energy
of interaction is minus Z times
e, the charge on the nucleus
times Z over 4 pi
epsilon nought r.
If Z is going up,
this interaction Coulombic
attraction becomes greater.
But at the same time,
we've got another parameter
here, and that's r.
And r, as you go across the
Periodic Table,
is remaining essentially
constant because you're in the
same shell.
So if you're in the same shell,
r is about constant.
And so the only thing really
changing is Z.
And so the electron affinity
goes up.
The same reason why the
ionization energy goes up as we
go across the Periodic Table,
as we talked about last time.
All right.
But now, in general,
let's look at going down the
Periodic Table here.
All right.
Fluorine.
Chlorine.
Bromine.
Iodine.
Well, in general,
the electron affinity actually
goes down.
And the electron affinity there
goes down because r is,
in general, getting larger.
You're putting electrons in
shells that are further and
further away.
Z is also getting larger,
but not fast enough compared to
r.
So, in general,
that electron affinity goes
down.
There are always some glitches,
but in general that is the
trend.
Okay.
So then, the other property
that I wanted to talk about is
the atomic radius.
And the atomic radius here is
plotted on the side.
And let's look at what happens
as we go across the Periodic
Table here.
Well, in general,
as we go across the Periodic
Table, the atomic radius is
going down.
The atomic radius is going down
because, again,
Z is going up.
The charge on the nucleus is
getting larger,
meaning that attractive
interaction is getting larger,
meaning that those electrons
are pulled in closer.
Now, as you go across the
Periodic Table again,
your r is remaining,
roughly speaking,
the same, in the sense that the
electrons are in the same shell
with the same principle quantum
number.
So, in general,
that's remaining the same.
So that's not changing.
It's Z that is changing as you
go across the Periodic Table.
And that is the dominating
factor, the change in Z.
The change in Z brings those
electrons in closer.
And, therefore,
the radius actually goes down.
And then what about down the
Periodic Table,
down a column?
Well, in this case,
as you go down the Periodic
Table, again,
Z is also increasing.
But it's r that is changing
faster than Z because you're
having electrons in shells that,
on the average,
are a farther distance away
from the nucleus.
And that is increasing more
rapidly than Z is increasing,
so, therefore,
this radius here is getting
larger.
All right.
So those are the three big
trends across the Periodic Table
that you should know.
Ionization energy and electron
affinity increase as you go
across, radius decreased.
Ionization energy and electron
affinity decrease as you go down
a column, radius increases.
That is something that you do
need to know.
Okay.
Now there is one other concept
or quantity that I want to make
you familiar with,
and that is something called
the electronegativity.
And the electronegativity is
really an empirical concept.
We're going to use the
definition gave by Mulliken in
1934, as opposed to Pauling's
definition.
Mulliken's definition is a
little bit more straightforward.
And the electronegativity is
often just labeled chi,
and it is given by one-half
times the quantity ionization
energy plus the electron
affinity.
That is out electronegativity.
So the electronegativity here
is kind of some average of the
ionization energy plus the
electron affinity.
The electronegativity is some
measure of the tendency of an
atom to accept an electron or to
donate electrons.
So if the electronegativity of
an atom is high that's a good
electron acceptor.
If the electronegativity of an
atom is low, well,
that's a good electron donor.
For example,
if you look at the Periodic
Table here and you look at
electronegativities,
the elements that have high
high chi here,
are in the upper right-hand
corner.
These atoms have large
electronegativities because they
have high electron affinities
and high ionization energies.
These atoms are good electron
acceptors.
They're good electron acceptors
because their electron affinity
is high.
The change in the energy when
you add an electron is very
large and negative meaning the
electron affinity is high.
They're good electron
acceptors.
They're also good electron
acceptors because their
ionization energy is high.
It is difficult.
You have to put a lot of energy
into the system to remove the
electron.
They're good electron
acceptors.
On the other hand,
if you look at the elements
down here in the left-hand lower
corner, these elements have low
chi.
They have low
electronegativities.
They are not good electron
acceptors.
Their electron affinity is low
and their ionization energy is
low.
So these elements here are good
electron donors.
Their ionization energy is low.
You don't have to put in as
much energy to pull an electron
off as you do for some of the
other elements.
They have low ionization energy
and low electron affinity.
All right.
So you can already suspect that
some of the strongest ionic
bonds are going to be made
between those elements with high
electronegativity and those with
low electronegativity.
Because in an ionic bond,
as we're going to talk about,
there is this unequal sharing
of electrons.
So strong ionize bonds are
typically made between elements
of high electronegativity and
elements of low
electronegativity.
All right.
And then finally one other
concept, or one other definition
that I just wanted to make sure
everybody was on the same page
with is this term here,
isoelectronic.
Isoelectronic means having the
same electron structure,
having the same electronic
structure.
All of these atoms and ions
have the 1s 2 2s 2 2p 6
electron structure.
So nitrogen here.
Nitrogen has added three
electrons.
That makes it minus three to
get this electronic structure.
Aluminum has pulled three
electrons off to get this
electronic structure.
These are isoelectronic.
And typically the common ions
that are found in nature are
ions that have this octet,
this inner gas kind of
structure to it like the neon
structure.
So, for example,
typically you will see a
nitrogen minus three
ion.
You won't see nitrogen minus
two because that
doesn't have the inner gas
configuration.
You will see oxygen minus two,
but you won't see
oxygen minus one,
because that doesn't have the
inner gas configuration.
All right.
So common ions in nature are
ions that have either added or
removed electrons to obtain that
inner gas configuration.
Okay.
So those were a little bit of
the odds and ends,
that I wanted to just make sure
that we all understood each
other about them.
And now what we're going to do
is we're going to move on,
and we're actually going to
start talking about what
chemistry is all about.
And that is the formation of
bonds.
We're going to take these atoms
now and we're going to put them
together and we're going to make
some chemical bonds.
So I am going to start to talk
about this just in terms of what
are the fundamental interactions
that are taking place in a
chemical bond.
So that's what I will do for
most of the rest of the hour
today, is to talk about those
fundamental interactions that
are common to all chemical
bonds.
And then at the end of the
hour, I'm going to tell you
about one very simple model for
bonding, which are these Lewis
diagrams.
And then in the next few days
we will look at some more
sophisticated models.
We'll look at molecular orbital
theory and we'll look at
hybridization.
That is the plan.
So today, just the elementary
principles behind chemical
bonds, the elementary
interactions and a start on
Lewis structures.
Let's take hydrogen.
That is going to be our
prototypical molecule.
If we have two hydrogen atoms
that are far apart,
well, we have the hydrogen
nucleus here,
which is positive and its
electron, which we'll call
electron A.
And they're sort of attached.
And way out here is another
hydrogen atom.
Here is the nucleus and its
electron, electron B.
And so in the separated atom
limit, the interaction that
we've got is the
electron-nuclear attraction.
This electron is attracted to
this nucleus and vice versa.
It's that electron-nuclear
attraction that is operable in
both of these hydrogen atoms.
But now, as these two atoms
come closer together,
well, this nucleus here is
bringing its electron along,
and this nucleus here is
bringing its electron along.
But what happens is,
as they get closer together,
this electron that was only
attracted to this nucleus,
nucleus A, now begins to
experience an attraction to
nucleus B.
And this electron that was
attached only to nucleus B
experiences an attractive
interaction here with nucleus A.
And it is that mutual
attraction of the electrons for
both nuclei that actually is the
force, the energy of interaction
that brings the two nuclei
together, and ultimately a
chemical bond is formed.
However, at the same time that
you now have this additional
attraction, this attraction,
say, of electron A not only to
its original nucleus,
but to the other nucleus,
at the same time as you bring
those two together,
well, you're bringing the
electrons together.
And the electrons have like
charges and they repel.
So, at the same time now,
we've got a repulsion,
an electron-electron repulsion
that is coming into play.
And, at the same time to that,
we're bringing the two nuclei
together, which are both
positively charged.
We've got a repulsion coming up
there also.
And so the formation of a
chemical bond here is an
interplay between three very
strong interactions,
this electron-nuclear
attraction, the
electron-electron repulsion,
and the nuclear-nuclear
repulsion.
And so what we want to take a
look at is how those energies
actually change.
And the components change as a
function of the distance between
the two nuclei.
That's what we are going to
look at today.
So I am going to take two
hydrogen atoms here,
H, H, and I am going to plot
the energy of interaction as a
function of the distance between
those two hydrogens.
So that distance between the
two hydrogen here is r.
That's the distance between the
two nuclei.
Now, I've changed my definition
of r.
Up until now we've been talking
about r as the distance between
the electron and the nucleus,
but I just changed it in this
discussion of the chemical bond.
It's the distance between the
two nuclei.
This is important.
Now let me plot this energy of
interaction here.
And I am going to write this as
energy.
This is the energy of
interaction.
It's going to be in kilojoules
per mole.
And I am going to plot it as a
function of r,
this distance between the two
nuclei.
And what I am going to find,
this is going to be my zero of
energy here, is that way out
here where the two hydrogen
atoms are separated,
this energy of interaction is
going to be minus 2624
kilojoules per mole.
So this is hydrogen plus
hydrogen,
hydrogen atoms infinity
separated.
But now I am going to bring
those two hydrogen atoms
together.
And what happens is that the
energy will go down.
The energy of interaction will
go down; it will keep going down
until some point,
and then it will start going
up.
And that energy of interaction
will be actually at some value r
here greater than what it was in
the separated atom limit.
Now, everywhere where this
energy of interaction is lower
than the separated atom limit --
Everywhere along these values
of r we have a chemical bond.
The two hydrogen atoms are
bound because their energy of
interaction is lower than that
of the two separated hydrogen
atoms.
Where it is the lowest,
where that energy of
interaction is the lowest is the
equilibrium bond length.
That's what defines the bond
length, is the value of r at
which that energy of interaction
here is the lowest,
is the most negative.
That's the equilibrium bond
length.
In the case of H two,
that bond length turns out to
be 0.4 angstroms.
Everywhere here,
where that energy of
interaction is lower than that
of the separated hydrogen atoms,
from here to here,
we call that the attractive
region of the potential energy
of interaction.
We call that the attractive
region, because everywhere here,
from here to here,
two hydrogen atoms are bound.
They are lower energy than that
of the separated hydrogen atoms.
So, in other words,
they are bound if they are at
this value of r.
They're bound if they're at
It's just that they are most
strongly bound at the
equilibrium bond length.
So that's how you read the
curve.
This well here,
if you will,
we call this sometimes a well,
that's the attractive region of
this energy of interaction
curve.
Sometimes we call it the
potential energy of interaction.
And then another important
definition here is the change
here from the bottom of this
well to the separated atom
limit, as you measure it from
the bottom to the separated atom
limit that energy change I'm
going to call delta E sub d.
This is the bond association
energy.
This is how much energy it's
going to require to dissociate
the H two molecule if it's
sitting in its equilibrium
position from here to here.
That turns out to be,
in kilojoules per mole,
432 kilojoules per mole.
That's the bond association
energy.
But you also notice here
something a little peculiar in
the sense that you can bring
these two hydrogen atoms in.
And, if you bring them in too
close, that is,
if you start to push them in
closer than their equilibrium
bond distance,
the energy of interaction goes
up.
And you can keep pressing them
in.
And the energy of interaction
will go even further up.
In other words,
will increase more as you push
those two hydrogen atoms in.
The energy of interaction can
get above that of the separated
hydrogen atoms.
And it's this region of the
potential energy of interaction
that we call the repulsive
region.
It's repulsive because if you
push those two hydrogen atoms
closer than about this point
right here, those two hydrogen
won't stick together.
They're even closer than the
bond length, but they're not
going to stick together because
their energy of interaction is
greater than the separated
hydrogen atom limit.
So that is, in general,
what the energy of interaction
looks like for every chemical
bond.
But this curve here is really
given by the competition and the
interplay between these three
interactions that I started
talking about right here.
And so I want to try to
decompose this curve into those
three interactions.
And that is what we're going to
do now.
We're going to try to explain
why that curve has the shape
that it actually has.
I started out saying that this
energy of interaction,
I will just call it energy of I
here, was really the sum of
three interactions.
One of those interactions was
the nuclear-nuclear repulsion
between the two nuclei.
That's one.
Another one of those
interactions was the
electron-nuclear attraction --
-- between the electron and
both nuclei, or between both
electrons and both nuclei.
And then finally,
the third, is this electron
repulsion between the two
electrons as we bring the two
hydrogen atoms closer together.
So those are the three
components.
Now, what I want to try to do
is I want to try to figure out
an r dependence for each one of
those components.
I want to see how each one of
those components change with r.
And then when I add that up,
I should get something that
looks like that.
Okay?
All right.
So how are we going to do that?
Well, first of all,
I am going to realize that with
a nuclear-nuclear repulsion,
what is that r dependence going
to look like?
You want to guess?
Coulomb interaction,
right?
Coulomb interaction between
like charges.
That's what that r dependence
is going to look like.
So that's e squared for the
hydrogen atom,
the charge on the nuclei.
Each hydrogen atom is e over 4
pi epsilon nought times r.
In the case of the
nuclear-nuclear repulsion right
here, I've got a very good
handle on what that r dependence
for that interaction energy
should look like.
How come I ran out of board
here?
Oh, wait a minute.
All right.
Let me draw that.
So I have the energy of
interaction here.
And I've got a zero of energy.
And so I'm drawing a 1 over r
dependence there.
Well, 1 over r looks like it
starts at infinity and drops off
to zero for very large values of
r.
So this is my nuclear-nuclear
repulsion.
That is this dependence right
over here.
I have one of the components,
but now what about the
electron-nuclear attraction and
the electron-electron repulsion?
Well, it turns out that I have
no simple way to predict the r
dependence for the
electron-nuclear attraction or
the electron-electron repulsion.
I have no simple way to do that
without doing a sophisticated
calculation.
And, in fact,
I don't even have a simple way
of doing that if I want to sum
these two terms.
These two terms are really the
electron interactions.
These two terms involve the
electron-electron repulsion,
electron-nuclear attraction.
This one didn't have any
electrons in it.
So I have no simple way to do
that.
However, what I can do is that
I can evaluate the sum of these
two energies at two extremes.
two energies when r is infinity
way over here,
and I can evaluate the sum of
those two terms when r is at
zero way over here.
So I am going to have two
points, and then I am going to
interpolate between those two
points to get my r dependence.
That's what I'm going to do on
my graph over there.
So let's do that.
I am going to erase this here.
Let's start by looking at what
that energy of interaction is at
r equal infinity.
At r equal infinity,
what is the electron-electron
repulsion equal to?
Zero, because the electrons are
very far apart.
There is no interaction there.
When r is equal to infinity,
what is the electron-nuclear
attraction?
I'm sorry?
What is the electron-nuclear
attraction?
I'm over here.
When r is infinity,
what is the energy of
interaction for the electrons in
the nuclei?
It's not zero because when the
two hydrogen atoms are
separated, in each hydrogen atom
the energy of interaction is?
How about the binding energy of
an electron to a nucleus,
right?
It is the binding energy of the
electron to the nucleus.
That's the binding energy of
the electron in the ground
state.
It's the binding energy of the
1s electron.
Make sense?
Does this make sense to you?
No it doesn't.
No.
Okay.
What's confusing?
You don't know.
Do you understand what I am
plotting here as a function of
r, the distance between the two
nuclei?
Okay.
When the two nuclei are very
far apart --
Right over here they're really
far apart.
There is no electron-electron
repulsion.
Because each electron is
attached to each nucleus and
they're too far apart for there
to be any repulsive interaction.
That makes sense,
right?
But when they are far apart
here the electron-nuclear
attraction, between this
electron and its nucleus here,
that electron-nuclear
attraction, that energy of
interaction is the binding
energy of the electron to the
nucleus.
In the case of the ground state
hydrogen atom it is the binding
energy of the 1s state.
Does that make sense?
Yes?
No?
Good.
But we've got two hydrogen
atoms so there is a two in front
of this.
We've got two hydrogen atoms so
there is a two in front of that.
And now, you know that the
binding energy of an electron to
a nucleus is -2.18x10^-18
joules, right?
Yeah, you know that.
I am going to turn that into
kilojoules per mole instead of
joules per molecule.
When I turn that into
kilojoules per mole,
it is 1312 kilojoules per mole.
If I multiply that by 2,
I am going to get 2624
kilojoules per mole.
And so way out here at r equals
infinity I've got one point
minus 2624 kilojoules per mole.
That is where that number came
from in this original graph.
Do you understand that?
This is important,
because these are the
interactions present in all
chemical bonds.
So we've got that.
Now we're going to estimate
what the sum of these two terms
are at r equals zero.
At r equals zero we've got the
electron-nuclear attraction and
we've got the electron-electron
repulsion.
How are we going to do this?
Well, at r equals 0,
what we've got are two hydrogen
atoms with the nuclei right on
top of each other because that's
what r equal zero means.
There is no distance between
the two nuclei,
right?
So we've got two protons right
on top of each other.
And, as far as we're going to
be concerned here,
if you've got two protons right
on top of each other that looks
like a helium nucleus.
If we've got two protons right
on top of each other at r equals
0, Z is going to be plus 2.
That is going to look like a
helium nucleus.
This is a thought experiment.
We're taking two hydrogen and
we're putting them right on top
of each other.
So you've got something that
looks like a helium nucleus,
Z equals 2.
And now, because r is equal to
0, we've got two electrons
around that helium nucleus.
So all of a sudden what we've
got here is something that looks
like a helium atom.
This looks like a helium atom
in this thought experiment.
How can I estimate the sum,
not these individuals,
but the sum of these
interactions in the helium atom?
In the helium atom we have the
electron-nuclear attraction,
the attraction between this
electron and the helium nucleus,
this electron and the helium
nucleus, and we've got the
repulsion between these two
electrons.
How can I estimate that?
Well, experimentally I can
estimate that by taking the
first ionization energy,
making that minus,
plus minus the second
ionization energy.
That will be my total energy of
interaction as far as the
electrons are concerned.
So I go and I look up the first
ionization energy of helium.
Remember the first ionization
energy was the energy required
to pull off the first electron?
I find that number.
The binding energy is minus
that ionization energy,
so that's why I put that minus
sign there.
I do that, and that removes one
electron.
And now, I want to know how
much is this electron bound to
the nucleus.
I go up and I look up my second
ionization energy for helium,
where I solve the Schrödinger
equation for a one electron
atom.
I look that up.
That's minus the ionization
energy.
It turns out that the sum of
those two is minus 7622
kilojoules per mole.
Does this make sense?
The electron-nuclear attraction
plus the repulsion --
I cannot separate those two
terms, but I know what they are
experimentally as a sum,
because I go and I measure how
much energy is required to pull
the first electron off,
add it to the energy required
to pull the second electron off.
That's totally the
electron-nuclear attraction plus
the electron-electron repulsion.
That's what that is.
And I have to make it negative
because the binding energy,
the energy interaction is minus
the ionization energy.
So way over here on this plot
I've got another point for r
equals 0.
That is minus 7622 kilojoules
per mole.
And so now what I'm going to do
is I am going to just draw a
line here between the two.
I just interpolate it because I
don't know what else to do.
I don't know how to get that
energy of interaction in a
simple way as a function of r in
any other way.
But now, what I've got are the
three components.
Here is one,
the r dependence.
Here is my approximation for
the r dependence of the sum of
the other two components.
I am going to add them up.
Because my total energy of
interaction I said was the sum
of those three.
And when I add them up,
well, what I am going to get,
if I add this curve to that
curve, I'm going to get
something that looks like that.
This is going to bring it down.
This goes to infinity,
so this will go high up to
infinity here.
I am going to get a potential
energy of interaction that looks
something like that.
The point of all of this was to
illustrate that a chemical bond
is really a result of the
competition between the electron
interactions.
The electron interactions are
this green line here.
It's a competition between the
electron interactions,
which is always negative.
Even though you have an
electron-electron repulsion
here, which is a repulsive
interaction, the overall energy
of interaction is negative.
It's attractive.
The electron interactions
overall are attractive.
They're negative.
So this chemical bond is a
competition between the electron
interactions,
which are attractive,
and the nuclear-nuclear
repulsion, which is always
repulsive.
This was always positive.
It's always repulsive.
And what you can see here is
that there is some optimal
distance which ends up being the
bond length, where the total
energy of interaction is a
maximum negative number.
Where the total energy of
interaction is the greatest.
In other words,
what you have to do is you're
going to make a chemical bond.
You have to bring the two atoms
in close enough so that the
electron attractions are
present, which bring the two
nuclei in.
But you cannot press them so
close together such that the
nuclear repulsions take over.
So there is some intermediate
distance here where you have
enough electron attraction,
but you don't push them so
close that the nuclear repulsion
takes over.
And it is that optimal distance
here that is the equilibrium
bond length.
Now, there is one other very
important point.
And that is that what we often
do is we shift this zero of
energy when we talk about a
chemical bond.
This zero of energy right now
is 2624 kilojoules above the
energy of the separated hydrogen
atoms.
But we already saw that this
energy of interaction is the
energy of interaction between
the electron and the nucleus in
the separated hydrogen atom
limit.
When we talk about a chemical
bond, we really want to know
what the energy of interaction
between the two hydrogen atoms
is.
And so it is useful for us to
take for us to take this zero of
energy here and just shift it
down and set it here,
make this the zero of energy.
Now our zero of energy is when
the two hydrogen atoms are
separated from each other.
That is just the convention.
It is often useful to talk
about chemical bonds when you
set the two atoms --
When they are far apart,
and you set that energy of
interaction equal to zero.
See you on Wednesday.